why don't we go next to a dylan from
massachusetts dylan you're on the air
dylan from massachusetts if you unmute
will be able to hear you
oh hey can you hear me yes i can oh
great uh how you doing david i'm doing
well
thank you uh so i want to talk about two
things i want to talk about
politics sorry what was the first thing
you cut out
i want to talk about healthcare and
geopolitics okay maybe let's pick one
because we have so many people waiting
to to get on
cool okay well we'll scrap the health
care then
what do you think uh uh american foreign
policy should look like for example
in the syrian civil war where we're
almost like a destabilizing force
because we're supporting uh
we're supporting technically non-state
groups and meanwhile you have russia and
iran
supporting the syrian governments and
you have you know france and turkey
also supporting different non-state
actors and it's it's just a
destabilizing
uh presence almost so what do you what
do you think
our role should be there's no single
answer i mean are you saying
specifically in syria or more generally
what
principle should be applied to
determining u.s foreign policy
um i'm i guess i'm talking more about
general principles i'm just
looking at this through the lens of the
syrian civil war but also similar
situations have arisen in iraq and
afghanistan as a result of u.s
involvement
well i think the problem is one that
came up uh last week
during live calls which is once we break
something or once we have a negative
effect
how long does our responsibility remain
and
i don't know the answer and that's a
really that's a really tough question
um the the other you know aspect of this
is that a lot of these conflicts
essentially become proxy
not necessarily wars sometimes they're
wars but sometimes they're proxy
geopolitics where
we're really up against as you mentioned
there's different there's different
nation states that support other
factions like in the syrian civil war
including russia and france and others
and so sometimes it's essentially just
becoming a proxy geopolitical conflict
and
obviously i would love to just come here
and say the u.s should get out of
everything and we should just you know
let everybody do whatever but it's just
not gonna happen
so i think we're better served by
thinking more pragmatically and
productively about about
what our involvement should be but the
problem really is when we break
something how long do we have to stick
around
how long do future presidents have to
stay because we did break it i mean you
know the
the afghanistan example with george w
bush is a good one i don't have the
answer i don't know how long we're
supposed to stick around
at what point can we say this is it and
we're
out even if we are the reason that
things are going so poorly the
i don't have an answer unfortunately
yeah i just think it's really sad that i
mean
especially in syria it's sort of almost
turned into like
well you know can we uh i feel like
defense contractors
not necessarily u.s defense contractors
but you know people trying to sell
weapons from russia
yeah and then like croatian weapons
stocks are appearing in
in syria and i feel like it's almost
it's almost like a way
where you can uh it's like an infinite
money source you can keep selling
weapons to these different groups and
perpetuate a conflict
no question of the people living there
there are economic uh
strategic decisions there are
geopolitical strategic decisions at play
and and most of it is essentially
terrible for just like the average
person who works for a living
yeah it's really sad yeah for sure all
right thank you very much for the call i
appreciate it a lot a lot of foreign
policy stuff going on today
many many things on people's minds